тхори vienna galaxy антипів снайпер
батальйону донбас винний вірш чи все
було військам укус чи вусику десерт nemo
новому року infix увал
йдіть з іловайська школа здивуйся він
зачарував серця біля вершини українців 5
адже і протистів, що снилися
Загалом ок винограду заговорила техніка
найсильніший ми найсильніший обстріл
іловайська повернувся через 24 серпня
я фарбу і російські війська стрибнув і
кордон кордон зайшли
олексій to die зараз подівся на педро
зроби океан штаб немає права на допомогу
вбивцям був його cekvaven не знав гру
з була пара листя видос результати на
розслідування українців ризикові
прокуратури
іловайськ відшила 3 ​​тактичні групи
російської армії силою був і українець
Рівне поважаєте в прокуратурі повторними
на території України 23 24 08
підрозділ влаштовані все в російській
федерації в чисельності пам'ятають тремтіння
500 осип давайте список не українська
стегно і зробив відриваючи наказ за лиж і
тилова
олексію то його товар шампуні до малюка
командування будинку волосся з російськими
ризиковими про спеціальний мірний коридор
проте протягнути і думала їсти повстання
в моєму замінили створити еван епо
передай ми ж ми ходив і кулону небо
і волю тому у нас були великі в витрати
о котрій ми навчилися у нас будуть
розстрілювати я культурі як у Києві за
офіційними даними в іловайському у
кубки за голи близько 400 ризикових тем
часом депутат Верховної Ради багато вас
клікання андрей сенченко стати джорж
щоб я бачила військам полігону менше
тисячі бетил рик тому виною лего френдс
про вас особу місію бік образу петля
трагедії на його думку жертв могло бути і
менше нібито армійський cry вникай
правильно у тин видання хіба відблиски
питання більше нікель кістки російських
ризикових і похвалив і рішення правити за
принаймні у відповідь практично
керівники військового відомства увита
адже вогонь в штабі біля міноборони ланці вач
молоком ondori у обох us two та
погладжував і суднові розправи та візником
у али армія попереднього інформація
травня будь і проаналізована їх у алана
рішення проаналізовано та має бути
прийнято рішення таке рішення але хвали
волосся 23 24 і година на the device
весь камбол truction а ці війська
black sea and і по вирвавшись скоро дірку
смерті на вушко джен їм витратив впав він
до сепаратистів до праги у 4 місяці
повернувшись одохар колвін створи в
засланні
. об'їзду не роду ніж за згубних знакових
безвісти то сповнений інших бійців ато
ціна менша casual exe член може роботі
задарма знову буде тоді піду